wilfrid riche et bien de nous rejoindre
pour parler politique il est question
une nouvelle fois de la primaire en vue
des présidentielles la primaire de la
droite et descentes bien sûr bonsoir
offrir un bon soir florane la primaire
de la droite et du centre évidemment un
quart pour la gauche il faudra attendre
le 18 juin le ps va décider ou non à
cette date de renouveler l expérience
comme en 2012 la primaire de la droite
donc une élection ouverte à tous qui a
en quelque sorte vampirisé la
présidentielle un premier tour avant le
premier tour près de 23% des français se
disent prêts à y participer selon une
enquête réalisée elle au tout début du
mois par le parisien et bfm tv pour
certains analystes eux mêmes celui qui
s'imposera alors de ce scrutin de cette
primaire en novembre sera sans doute le
prochain président est aujourd'hui
toujours en tête dans les sondages c'est
alain juppe aussi alain juppé qui
devançait nicolas sarkozy même si ce
dernier n'est pas encore candidat
officiellement viennent ensuite bruno le
maire françois fillon ou encore nathalie
kosciusko morizet les candidats
multiplient les déplacements depuis
plusieurs semaines ils occupent leur
terrain
leur comité de soutien prennent forme la
semaine dernière celui d'alain juppé à
d'ailleurs fait venir et christine
albanel s'était à versailles christine
albanel
et c'est cet ancien ministre de nicolas
sarkozy à la longtemps rédiger les
discours aussi de jacques chirac avant
d'occuper le poste de présidente de
l'établissement public du château de
versailles de 2003 à 2007 pour ensuite
aller s'installer à la culture et à la
communication jusqu'en 2009 alors
pourquoi cette implication aujourd'hui
aux côtés d'alain juppé à derna juppé on
écoute sa réponse au micro de fanny
bourdillon alain juppé n'a pas fait un
choix de payet n'a pas fait un choix de
faux semblants il veut dire très
précisément ce qu'il fera c'est très
simple il dit je ferai un mandat je vais
venir pendant cinq ans je vais faire le
job et je vais tout donner
avec mon expérience avec ce que je suis
avec mon âge aussi que j'assume
totalement
et puis voilà et je ferai ce que j'ai
dit mais j'ai aussi passé 20 ans de ma
vie avec jacques chirac
il y a une famille quand même chirac
hier
avec un certain angle de vision des
choses de valeur une façon de de prendre
d'abord d'elle
la vie politique est pour moi je peux
c'est quelqu'un qui fait partie de cette
famille alors christine albanel qui dans
le même temps ne mâche pas ses mots
envers nicolas sarkozy
elle considère que l'ancien président
était trop dans la communication il
avait je cite plus une stratégie de
communication que d'action c'est
l'ancien ministre qui le dit il faut
dire que les rapports entre les deux
n'ont pas toujours été au beau fixe
lorsque nicolas sarkozy a par exemple
annoncé en 2008 la suppression de la
publicité sur france télévisions
christine albanel était donc sa ministre
de la culture et elle n'était même pas
au courant de la sarkozie a été beaucoup
dans la communication et je le sais
parce que je supportais moi même
d'ailleurs de loin
bon ben c'est la communication je pense
qu'alain juppé ne pas en dehors de
communication bien sûr il ya des règles
aujourd'hui de nos sociétés politiques
modernes bien entendu mais c'est vrai
que pour lui la réflexion de la
sincérité de l'engagement et ensuite
l'action prime un effet nettement sur la
communication
c'est vrai qu effectivement elle ne
mâche pas ses mots que pense de ces
propos nicolas sarkozy ça on ne sait pas
trop forcément ils évitent le sujet une
chose est sûre en tout cas pour le
nicolas sarkozy pour lui le chemin est
encore long pour convaincre de sa
légitimité sur cette nouvelle
candidature un dernier chiffre j'aime
bien les chiffres dans cette chronique
politique 72%
72% des français qui ne souhaite pas que
le patron des républicains se présentant
dès 2017 c'est libération qui l'a publié
en début de semaine ce sera ton